[Applause]
yep okay yeah today I'm going to talk
about wheat supervision but before I
start the presentation I have to thank
my team who did most of the research on
this project so I've just done like the
classic manager technique of delegating
the work and now I'm taking on the glory
by presenting it as my own work so got
to thank my team for the hard work yep
so Who am I as my introduction said and
currently director of machine learning
at Rathlin Ravel ins a fraud detection
company we have about five data
scientists five analysts and some
engineers and other supporting staff
that all work on machine learning side
rattling so fraud detection company we
detect various kinds of financial crimes
before that a fashion company called
list also running the data science team
and before that I was doing my PhD in a
in a obscure useless branch of maths so
frauds there are many types of fraud
many types of financial crimes the kind
of financial crimes that we care about
are mostly crimes that affect merchants
so the interesting thing about the
financial payment system there are a
couple of interesting things about it
surprisingly is that when you buy
something on the internet with the
credit cards the banks and the schemes
have wrangled it so that they are no
longer responsible for fraud if the
credit card doesn't exist in person it's
down to the merchants instead so we work
with merchants to protect them from
attacks against the sort of thing so we
mainly work card-not-present which is
online transactions but there's also a
bunch of other types of fraud like when
people's accounts gets hacked or when
the actual sellers are defrauding we've
had situations where people create fake
restaurants and order to the fake
restaurant and make money that way or
also things like friendly fraud where
you as a consumer ring up your credit
card company and pretend you've been
defrauded to get the money back
can get the goods for free so all sorts
of different types of fraud for that now
I probably don't need to talk to a room
data scientist about how important
labels are but they're incredibly
important to us and quite hard to
collect and I know it's the same in many
other domains or they can be expensive
or even like ethically objection ly
ejection or to collect but the biggest
jumps in machine learning we've seen in
the past years is all thanks to new
labelled data sets so if you look at
something like image now image net is
responsible for the massive jumps we saw
in image processing using CN NS and deep
learning and that sort of stuff
and if we didn't have a good label data
set we wouldn't have been able to make
the progress we did so let me talk a bit
about fraud labels so the main label we
have on fraud is called a chargeback
that's when you ring up your bank and
say I didn't make this transaction then
the bank tells your bank tells the
scheme which is Visa Visa tells the
merchant the merchant tells a bus so you
have this really long cycle it can take
anywhere between like two weeks and four
months just to get a charge back on a
transaction so the labels are really
high-quality but they're really slow to
get to us
so I mean that raises some problems for
us because if we train a model and we
want to deploy it and we want to be
really sure that this models going to
detect frauds
we're really training on data that's
four months old and then we're using
that model on data that's recent so you
have to put in loads of work to make
sure you don't deploy a broken model and
I think there's been quite a few
presentations of this pi days are all
about how to be sure the model you're
deploying is good so I'm happy to see
more people are thinking about that
another big problem with chargebacks and
one of the reasons we're looking into
weak supervision is the better we do as
a company and the better we do for our
clients the fewer labels we get because
each person we detect is fraudulent we
block from trance
and then so we do not get a chargeback
for them and we can end up in this
situation where we get very very few
chargebacks those chargebacks are for
really hard cases of frauds so we end up
overfitting on these really hard cases
and the model almost forgets about the
easy cases and we start letting easy
ones through again so it's really
important we can somehow add
common-sense to our model even if we're
not getting active labels about these
common-sense data points and that's
another thing weak supervision can do
for us so there are good labels we also
have many many other sources of labels
of dubious quality and it'd be really
awesome it because somehow use these
dubious quality labels to inform our
model and sort of remove ourselves from
being fully reliant on chargebacks so
some sources of dubious labels would be
say manual reviews from our clients so
things clients go into our dashboard and
manually say this is for all this is and
sometimes those reviews are really
amazing
sometimes those reviews are really
terrible and it just exposes the biases
of the person doing the review so and
many of the sources we have other things
we have rules we have networks we have
similarity methods we have something
called 3ds feedback that's when the bank
asks you to put your password then when
you buy something online so we have all
these different sources but none of them
are good enough to use as a true
supervised label so that's where weak
supervision comes in so one way we can
think of weak supervision is putting
into this hierarchy of sort of machine
learning techniques you know typically
with supervised learning we have some
high quality labels or as high as
possible and we don't really do anything
with low quality labels we just exploit
the things we really know a good labels
then you have something in the middle of
semi-supervised learning sending
supervised learning we use all our good
labels and then we use our good labels
to label unlabeled data so who are
basically exploiting sort of similarity
and structural characteristics of the
features
and like continuity our manifolds and
all those sorts of proximity based
methods to propagate labels to our
unlabeled cases and this quote works
quite well but you are limited in the
sort of things you're going to be
labeling and then there's weekly
supervised where we can make use of our
high quality labels and our low quality
labels so made this little diagram
before I explain exactly what it is so
you see in the supervise case we're just
taking your things we really know about
in the semi-supervised we take the
things we really know about and then add
a little bit more on that are close to
our good labels in the weekly supervised
case we're sort of just shotgunning the
whole instance space with potential
labels I'm going to talk about how we do
that one thing I should say about fraud
and why this is useful to us we really
only have negative labels we only know
that someone is a fraud so when we get a
charge back for them and people who
don't have a charge back we can't say
they're good people they might also be
fraudsters but we just don't have a
signal saying they're forces we have no
like explicit positive signals so for us
this sort of setup makes quite quite
sent a lot of sense where we only care
about fraudulent negative labels and
this area is sort of unknown and we sort
of assumed they're good people but that
but they might not be another way we can
think of weak supervision is sort of in
the hierarchy of machine learning
techniques over time right so in the 70s
when AI was a I and not like a marketing
term we had like expert systems where
people entered a load of rules into a
database and this was a I write and the
rules triggered and we and we like gave
a diagnosis to a patient or something
and that was expert systems where your
engineering the actual decision
functions then we have sort of the 90s
where machine learning starts coming up
and there we're automating the decision
functions but manually engineering the
features then we sort of more recently
we've got the deep techniques coming up
where we're not engineering the decision
function we're not engineering the later
the features were engineering an
architecture of the model and automating
the previous forms of things that we
were engineering and then you can think
a weak supervision as the next step
where we're now engineering the labels
themselves and a lot and a lot of the
work could be in constructing the labels
were training on in a sensible way which
sounds a bit strange right
because labels are a universal truth we
shouldn't be engineering them but but
weak supervision proposes some methods
that we can use to do that so how does
it work well I've got this very
confusing diagram from the weak
supervision paper oh yeah I should say
that most of the work on weak super
recent work on weak supervision is all
from the group that makes the tool
called snorkel it's a Python library to
do weak supervised learning their sites
amazing the extremely prolific they make
it there's so many papers and blog posts
on this I'll give you the address later
but this is a picture from the snorkel
site and there's an overview at how weak
supervision works you your training data
you treats as normal but you generate
your labels by taking a lot of weak
sources so here you know they've got you
know an NLP taggers you could just have
rules on your text that say does the
text contain angry okay we think the
sentiment is is negative you know you
can just add these really loose rules
that you could never add as a true label
because they aren't precise enough but
you can create all these weak sources
here so it's kind of also you can think
of it a bit like an ensemble but instead
of ensemble insomnia labels and
basically those go into this another
model a generative model which optimizes
not using labels and it produces a
probabilistic label that goes into our
traditional machine learning model with
our traditional feature
that's a general way it works so what do
our labeling functions look like they're
pretty simple they take in an instant so
one feature vector or one sentence or
whatever the input to your model is on
the return one of three values minus one
if you think there's evidence for your
label whatever you're detecting in our
case it'd be fraud one if there's no
evidence for what you think is fraud and
then zero if there's no evidence so in
the no evidence case for us it could be
you know we might have a rule that says
does the user have more than 5 credit
cards in one day that would be a
suspicious signal but it might not
necessarily be fraud it could there
could be a genuine user so we would say
minus 1 if they have more than 5 cards 1
if they have less than five cards and
perhaps you would return zero if they've
never added a cards because they haven't
they haven't had the opportunity to
prove or disprove that guilt yet because
they haven't done anything so you can
return zero in that case so the idea is
you come up with loads of these labeling
functions of this form oh yeah so some
examples of other things you can do so
rules is very typical one can also take
labels from humans which are notoriously
unreliable depending on the human we use
graft methods you can lose similarity
methods like we like semi-supervised
learning you can use model predictions
from worse models and the new version of
snorkel which hasn't come out yet but
it's even got support for things like
perturbative feature vectors
transforming data inputs to
automatically generate new labeling
functions so for example if you think of
something like image data you can't
really do rules on image data be very
tricky unless you have some extra
metadata so one of the examples that
they use in a paper is they segment
objects and tag those objects from an
image and then they do rules on the
segmented method
but it also support for transformation
so you can do stuff like write labeling
functions that just like share or craft
or rotate images to add regularization
and that sort of stuff yep so yep that's
it mostly and the idea is once you train
the label model you should end up with
something like this so we start with our
labels we're really really sure about
and these we sort of don't really know
about then we come up with all these
labeling functions that tag various
things as fraudulent the labeling
function is like we've just talked about
and then once you've learned the model
hopefully you're probabilistic label
that you're generative model comes out
with looks something like this so
instead of just having our tiny dot
which is effectively like a probability
one label for the confidence we have in
that label we end up with this spectrum
of labels across from zero to one about
how suspicious this person looks based
on a combination of all the labeling
functions we have so so this is the
paper that describes how the generative
model works I read it yesterday I know
my intentions were to have a really good
explanation for exactly how it worked
but it's quite complicated and the
notation is quite confusing I think but
the nice summary for it is essentially
it's like a correlation aware generative
probabilistic model that learns a latent
variable which is the probability that
that instance is fraudulent an input is
just all your labeling functions for
that instance and your output is just
the probability like the latent factor
it's learning and it uses factor graphs
but if you want to know more feel free
to read this paper if you figure out
exactly how it works please comment or
something that'll be very useful so
that's the generative component that
generates our probabilistic labels the
other component is just the
discriminative model that can be
anything you want it doesn't have to be
a deep model but all the literature ana
travellin we're using deep models
the reason being that whatever model you
use it has to be able to support a
probabilistic label so something like a
random forest isn't going to work
all that all the literature and Ravel in
the loss of these discriminative models
is normally log loss or binary cross
entropy as it's called a many deep
learning frameworks the reason being
that you know for this loss this Y can
be a 1 or 0 and the loss works this y
can also just be a probability in the
loss what's exactly the same so most
literature so far is using this sort of
loss okay so is there any good so we we
gave us a test on some of our data we
came up with I think is maybe about 20
labeling functions which isn't so many
and then we trained it and saw how it
did so when we tried it out we got about
two percent additional recall with yet
20 labeling functions and for us two
percent recall is actually really good
because our models are most our models
extremely mature good at exploiting all
the low-hanging fruits so a 2% recall
introduced recall increase is pretty
decent the other thing to think about
with this technique is one of the big
advantages is if you don't have any
labels right we have labels already
they're good but if you have zero labels
and you create a model that actually
works well then your increase in
performance is gonna be you know an
infinite increase right from zero to
something right it's gonna be massive so
if you've got no labels there's a good
technique to consider but when something
a bit strange about it but you need to
think about so here we said we've got a
2% 2% increase of recall but we can only
measure this because we have labels we
know about right we have good labels
already like there's a problem how do
you evaluate your model on your
generated labels if you don't already
have labels to evaluate on so that's
quite tricky
depending on your use case that might be
fine you know if you're a b2c company
and you can deploy to production and
track click-through then you can
evaluate based on that but if you're
something like custom fraud we have to
know how well the model performs before
we deploy it so it becomes quite tricky
to decide on how do you evaluate this
model when you're generating the labels
yourself and surely one of the reasons
we want to generate labels is so we get
a broad ability to set fraud and if
we're evaluating the model on our own
labels are we just optimizing the model
to predict the label we already have
write all the generated labels actually
doing anything useful for us I mean
that's a question I haven't answered
either but these are things that came up
as we're thinking about it and another
bad case is like I think we clearning is
painted as like this savior technique
where you just define some labeling
functions doesn't matter what they are
trainer model everything's brilliant but
like how do you even define these
labeling functions so if you think of a
rule-based approach on a feature vector
you just say is X bigger than Y then it
counts as a good label for us that's
what that's the sort of labeling
functions we have do you have more than
5 credit cards right but what you choose
for your threshold there do you choose
like 2 credit cards of 5 or 6 can you
have multiple thresholds multiple
labeling functions that have all sorts
of different thresholds it's really hard
to decide and when we talked about this
we said well why don't we just optimize
our thresholds based on our chargebacks
based on our true labels but this is a
terrible idea as well because in that
case you've basically created a really
bad random forest right you've created
just some some rules with some splits
and then you're optimizing the splits
and it's a terrible random forest so why
don't we just train a random forest
instead and forget about all this so I
mean there's some questions I have
basically and with and I'm not against
snorkle at all I'm still we're still
trying to figure out what's the best way
to do this I think at the moment there's
a lot of work on the theory and a lot of
high level case studies but there's not
much work on sort of best practices and
that's what we're trying to figure out
another problem we have well it's not
problem is we know we have in a really
good label but we can't incorporate that
into the model because the current
framework doesn't support basically
different classes of labeling function
saying one is more important than the
other but there is a blog post on
snorkel that vaguely mentions something
that's coming and it's actually pretty
simple how they do it they just split
their network into two branches put the
important labeling functions in one
unimportant ones and the other optimized
learn them separately mix them together
with the weight so you can sort of
approximate it that way but they're
talking about it in terms of NLP here
but if you weren't doing NLP features
you just sort of split it weight them
back together to try and give the
ability to have separate weights for
different classes of labeling functions
so we'll probably be doing that now
they're really sorry the really
important thing for weak learning is
something called this labeling function
instant density and this thing I think
isn't really highlight as much in the
literature but this is critical to
getting a good week learning system so
you can imagine this diagram here so so
let's say the y-axis is every instance
every feature vector the x-axis are all
our labeling functions and then each
cell is basically did we return a 0 or 1
or a minus 1 for that labeling function
on that feature vector the density of
this diagram is incredibly important to
the performance of the week supervision
system so there's a bit so with this
labeling functions is a bit of a
Goldilocks issue so here's a quote from
one of the papers in the low-density
setting are you when you don't have many
labeling functions per instance sparsity
labels will mean that there is a limited
room for even optimal weighting of the
labeling function to Verge much from the
majority votes so what's just saying
here is if you don't have many labeling
functions it's just going to use
majority vote
not even bothered to learn a generative
model so this means you know if you have
to labeling functions it's just gonna
say oh you both said one so we'll say
this is a fraud stir we'll say this is a
a label one and I think the problem with
that and it's not so public is that if
you design your labeling functions
likely suggest which is just like very
free and not really worrying about how
good they are and then you have this low
density scenario you're labeling
functions are basically devolving into
traditional supervised labels right so
if we have this labeling function that
says more than five credit cards and we
don't have enough labeling functions
that more than five credit cards is just
going to become a traditional supervised
label and our models going to suffer for
it so you really need to be able to
track this and then in the upper bound
case it's the same when the upper bound
case you don't need the generative model
if you have so many labeling functions
you can just do majority weighting and
it's just as good it's kind of the
middle ground where we use a generative
model and get the probabilistic label so
this is something you should definitely
monitor if you look in the paper I
linked before they have equations for
the lower bound and upper bound of
density that you should be looking to
sit in between yeah and here's another
yeah I think this just sums up the
questions that still need to be answered
with this snorkel work so this is a
quote from a blog I'm not gonna call out
who it is because there's a really good
blog and they write really good stuff
but my concern about this is really
these two things you know these labeling
functions do not need to be precise and
we meet and we should write many of them
I think there's just a lot of questions
around how many do we need to write can
we build supporting tool to the tools to
tell us how many we should write and
they do not need to be precise I think
there's lots of questions around
balances on precision and recall and
what labeling what the architecture ring
of your label function should be like
so if you want to take a deep dive into
snorkel go to this go to this place this
is their official website they're
constantly posting articles they're
constantly doing blogs constantly
posting papers there's loads of great
information here I just don't say like
my experience of snorkel we're super
positive about it we just think needs to
do a bit more work it could be that
we've missed papers or we've missed best
practices or anything if anyone's worked
with snorkel love to chat with them
about their experiences as well yes to
go to this website if you want the
current current research street
streamline your labeling see see what
it's all about this is the best one but
better efficiency better efficient
the results sure are unbreathable No
oh yeah sorry one thing if you like the
sound of this you like the sounds of
fighting crime and you like puns then
we're hiring loads of people at moment
date scientists analysts directors
any questions
sorry
that was really interesting one question
and you kind of yeah that's interesting
I guess it depends yeah that's quite
interesting I mean in one way it gives
you more explain ability because you
know what labeling functions triggered
for that customer so you've got maybe an
extra source of explained ability I mean
a travelin most of the explained ability
we do is very black box so we don't look
inside the model we you know manipulate
input and look at the output and see
what's happened so that so in terms of
that it doesn't really affect the
explained ability we're doing but yeah I
think you actually get more explained
ability through the labeling functions
that's quite yeah that's quite
interesting didn't think about
I griddle and my little thought when you
mentioning that you have can you pump
something you're leaping functions yeah
yeah yeah we so we use up sampling now
anyway to make things more important say
like a certain country or something like
that but yeah that's true you could up
sample your labeling functions here
yeah so on the second question yeah I
think you have to do it based on domain
knowledge cuz I mean you could protect
like we say you can potentially automate
it if you have some golden set of labels
but I'm not sure you know ultimately
generate these to maximize some
performance metric but I'm not sure if
that's a great idea because you're just
replicating your golden set of labels
instead so I think yeah you have to do
it using domain knowledge and experts
but there's definitely a question of how
do you evaluate if that was a if that's
goods and sorry what's the first
question all regression yeah I don't
know if you know I don't know if it's I
haven't seen anyone use it on a
regression problem I'm not sure what you
do for that rambling we have we have our
own graph database and in that graph
database we connect every customer that
we've ever viewed by all their sort of
entities so we say this customers
connected this customer because they've
once shared a phone number or they
shared a device or they and we have a
big multi hop network and we use that as
a true label if if a customer say two
customers connected and one of them has
a charge back we'll treat that as a true
supervised label but we have much more
distant relationships like oh this
customers connected by eight hops to a
customer the charge back and we wouldn't
treat that as a true label because the
distance is too far but we can start
treating that as a probabilistic
labeling function or we can say
something like a customer doesn't it
doesn't have a charge back but they have
one hundred and eighty devices that's
like it's not fraud but it's really
vicious why have you got 180 devices
right so we can start adding stuff like
that into the model like evidence-based
approach
hey thanks for the talk you mentioned
that it takes like months for you to get
charged back to labels yeah how do you
verify the performance of your models
when you play online and you make sure
that's not doing anything crazy yeah I
mean I could probably do a whole
presentation on this and I have in fact
but it's really tricky wait I mean
people have done talks here along
similar topics but we just try and take
everything we can from software
engineering and apply it to machine
learning we have unit tests that run on
the model the machine learning not to
verify the code works but to verify the
predictions are sensible we have an
automatic report that gets generated for
every single train model that has loads
of Diagnostics we look at things like
the distribution of score over various
features to make sure it's not doing
anything crazy we have dark mode which I
think someone has talked about this
conference already where we run two
models side by sides
they both score only the one result goes
to the client or the result just gets
stalled so then we can do analysis on
the score distribution how it changed
over time so you basically have to
employ all these heuristics and checks
and double-checks and loads of analysis
each to make sure you're not going to
break something because though it's even
worse for us because if we deploy a bad
model we have to wait four months before
we know it's bad and we take it out and
they've still got four months of bad
chargebacks coming in so it's like a
horrendous so you think like maybe you'd
have a probability for each class I
think that would be doable because the
very least you could just do a one you
can just do one versus all right on
every binary and then built and then
have n generative models and you have n
prop but then it was
decision functions even need right yeah
yeah I I don't I haven't seen any
literature that actually does that but I
think no I think that's more likely than
the regression scenario which should
have no idea how you do a regression
problem like this
[Applause]